the next key piece of preparation advice  is that you should really do mock tests  and the one that I like best that I've  had like resembled most the actual test  in the end was the Manhattan mock test  so after two or three days of studying  so after I got the basic concept of what  the Gmail was all about I decided to  take the very first mock exam to set a  baseline for myself so to understand  from where I'm starting and I remember  that after these two or three days I  scored slightly above 600 from then on  one time per week and sometimes even two  times per week I took a new version of  the mock exam to track my progress and  understand where I'm standing this  helped me to get a live feedback whether  I'm on the right path whether learning  the starting that I'm doing is really  helping me to Advance my score